on this saturday night
rapid testing for covid19 the need for
speed as the vicious virus
mutates i'm worried that the uk variant
is much more widespread
a made in canada solution given a second
chance
the uproar in russia over the detention
of vladimir putin's enemy
remembering the king of talk with an
angel
and his most memorable interviews plus
the treasure found at a thrift store
holy smokes
this is a lot of money and the employees
who did the right thing
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with some positive
news in the fight against covet 19.
an ottawa made rapid test has finally
been approved for use
the spartan cube promises to deliver
results in less than an
hour it was touted as a game changer at
the beginning of the pandemic
but there was a problem and it took
months to meet health canada standards
as abigail beeman reports it's one tool
to fight what remains a major health
crisis it has the enzymes needed
redesigning the reagent testing solution
took spartan bioscience
longer than it hoped now it can be kept
at room temperature instead of frozen
so it can be used anywhere rapid point
of care
easy use diagnostics for coca-19 will
really alleviate
the spread of kubernetes more than a
central lab can do for
a lot of situations health canada has
given the spartan cube the green light
the company says in large part because
of a different easier fix
the original problem was only with their
proprietary testing swabs
we were using our existing swab that was
made for it to swab a cheek swab
it wasn't made to swab your nose in the
back of your throat
to get rna or to get viruses particles
on it so spartan simply switched out the
swab for a regular
nasopharyngeal swab already on the
market it says it will start shipping
out back orders to the federal
government this coming week
and provinces which ordered directly
within a month
a separate hopeful pandemic sign a drop
in new coven 19
cases nationally we can breathe a brief
sigh of relief we are seeing numbers
drop significantly in certain areas like
alberta and
lake quebec we're seeing numbers come
down a bit in british columbia
and ontario biostatistician ryan imgrun
says
that doesn't mean we can relax
especially when we don't know how
widespread the uk variant
is i know this may come as a worry it's
our first exposure to this variant
friday nova scotia recorded its first
case and
one of the south african variant lab
testing now confirming people who had it
in
december while in ontario we're
in a deepening crisis we have a resident
dying long-term care every hour now
my hospital has been you know what we
consider ground zero for kobe
in ontario we for actually a few months
we have been at capacity in terms of our
uh met our cove awards our medicine
awards as well as our icu
and particularly a few weeks ago we were
transferring significant
number of patients emergency room dr
lisa solomon is now cautiously
optimistic
probably the first time in a long time
that i had a shift
with no resuscitations and no really
critically ill patients
solomon says things may be plateauing
after a big post-christmas spike but no
one should let their guard down
friday the prime minister said he's
sending two field hospitals to the
greater toronto area
solomon says that's a band-aid solution
and what's really needed
is the vaccine abigail beeman global
news
ottawa an ontario teen who worked at a
long-term care facility has died of cova
19.
few details are known for privacy
reasons health authorities will only say
the case involved a male
but wouldn't clarify his age or if there
were any underlying health
issues we have confirmation tonight the
highly contagious
uk variant is behind a serious outbreak
at an ontario long-term care
center genome sequencing on all six
samples tested from roberta placenberry
have now been identified as the variant
first found in the united kingdom
127 residents have contracted the virus
accounting for nearly
everyone who lives there 84 employees
have also tested positive
that's half the staff to date 32
residents from roberta place
have died from covet 19. ontario
is expanding its blitz of big box stores
and other essential businesses this
weekend
inspectors will now be paying visits to
stores in ottawa windsor niagara and
durham regions
corporations can be fined a thousand
dollars for failing to comply
with ontario's public health orders
the race to vaccinate more americans
against covet 19
is on president joe biden has set the
ambitious goal of 100 million shots
in his first 100 days in office in order
to do that
the u.s will need to ramp up vaccine
production
and distribution and as jennifer johnson
explains
it's also contending with new variants
taking hold across the u.s
in the race to get vaccinated north
carolina residents lined up around the
charlotte motor speedway to get their
shots
before the supply ran out it was
seamless it was amazing
it was well organized across america
vaccination centers are running into
roadblocks
at least 15 sites in new york city have
been forced to shut down
because there are no doses left other
states and cities are also seeing their
supplies
quickly dwindle i think we have to be
realistic with it
that if you aren't over the age of 65
and if you don't have health conditions
it's going to be probably in the summer
before
before it's available president joe
biden is pledging to get 100 million
shots administered in 100 days
by boosting production through the
defense production act and creating
federal vaccination centers
god will he not only do 100 million
we're going to do more than that
biden's team says its biggest challenge
is getting more vaccination sites
additional pharmacies and mobile clinics
up and running quickly
because if we don't set those up then
we'll be in a place in perhaps a month
or so where we're sitting on too much
supply
at a time when many people want to get
the vaccine we can
complicating the battle new strains of
the virus from countries including the
uk
spain and south africa that are more
aggressive and possibly even more deadly
old guidelines are changing say it took
ten minutes of a conversation
four feet apart for me to give enough
particles to you to spread the virus
now that number is half or a third
and so much more transmissible as
president biden pushes for all americans
to wear masks
the u.s coveted 19 death toll continues
to mount
expected to hit 500 thousand americans
next month
jennifer johnson global news washington
the senate impeachment trial for former
president donald trump will begin next
month
arguments are set to get underway in the
democrat-controlled senate the week of
february 8.
trump is facing a single charge of
incitement of insurrection
he's accused of rallying up the mob that
stormed the u.s capitol earlier this
month
senate leaders reached a deal to delay
the proceedings to february
to allow trump's legal team more time to
prepare
trump is the only president in u.s
history to be impeached
twice if he's convicted he could be
disqualified from holding public office
ever again the trudeau government is
standing behind the process
used to appoint now former governor
general julie payet
payet resigned as canada's vice regal on
thursday
the stunning move followed reports of a
scathing independent review
into allegations of a toxic work
environment under payette's watch at
rideau hall
mercedes stephenson joins us with more
on the government's response to the
resignation
mercedes robin never before have
canadians seen a governor general
resign in disgrace the unprecedented
move means the chief justice of the
supreme court of canada
will fulfill the governor general's
duties until a replacement is found
payette's departure is again raising
questions
about how she got the job in the first
place
prime minister trudeau opted to abandon
the advisory committee
that the harper government had put in
place for vice regal appointments
a move that in hindsight might now seem
ill-advised
but so for the trudeau government isn't
promising to reinstate that committee
here's what the intergovernmental
affairs minister dominic leblanc
told me we've already had conversations
with the officials that typically do
this kind of work to ensure that
anything going forward the vetting
process is strengthened is reinforced
we have enormous respect for the women
and men who work at rideau hall
also on the show this week i'll speak
with the u.s charge the fairs catherine
brucker
on what ottawa should expect from joe
biden and his administration
and alberta premier jason kenney
explains why he wants canada to hit back
at the u.s
over president biden's decision to nix
the keystone
xl pipeline robin mercedes stephenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes
and you can watch the west block
tomorrow right here on global
it's election season in newfoundland and
labrador
the province is going to the polls next
month in the latest campaign to take
place
during the pandemic three other
provincial leaders took the same gamble
and saw it pay off but as ross lord
explains
the liberal's timing of the election
call is raising eyebrows
in a province where covet 19 is almost
non-existent
public opinion polls suggest the
liberals of newfoundland and labrador
might use that success to go from a
minority government to a majority
having become premier automatically
after winning the liberal leadership
andrew fury needs a mandate but fury has
chosen an unusual time for an election
february 13th the dead of winter there's
always an excuse not to have an election
but democracy has to proceed and this is
the law i didn't make the law but
as i said from day one i'm going to
follow along following the law now
by going to the polls now rather than
waiting until spring
fury has raised suspicions that he's not
being totally transparent
critics like pc leader chess crosby say
he's trying to snatch victory before the
upcoming release of a review into the
province's horrid finances
a review that could lead to cuts and job
losses
this political analyst says it's a
landmine for fury
it's never good when you are a political
party a governing party
and you are hiding things so as long as
you're hiding things
uh the opposition can say there's a
wicked evil hidden agenda here
and that plays to people's fears so
that's where it's a serious problem for
the liberals they need to get a handle
on that issue
fury a medical doctor suggests the
province needs tough medicine
but he insists fears of the economic
review
are overblown first of all there is no
report there hasn't been a pen to paper
so far premiers who've gone to the polls
during the pandemic are glad they did
three provincial elections in recent
months all favored governing parties
new brunswick's pc government led by
blaine higgs
added seven seats turning a fragile
minority government into a majority
in bc john horgan's new democrats also
went from minority to majority by adding
16 seats and scott mo's saskatchewan
party defended its majority
picking up two more seats than it had
before the election call
we put faith in our leaders because we
have to because we're in an emergency
situation
and we need some sort of guidance
newfoundlanders must now decide if they
too will place their faith
in the incumbent party ross lord global
news
more than 3 000 demonstrators have been
arrested in russia
including alexi navalny's wife
about 5 000 people packed into moscow
city center
demanding the opposition leader be
released clashes broke out with police
trying to shut down the demonstration
navalny had called on his supporters to
protest his arrest
last week one of vladimir putin's
biggest critics
navalny had returned to russia for the
first time since being poisoned
with a nerve agent
and one of navalny's political allies
was also arrested while doing a live tv
interview
rallies in support of navalny erupted in
60 cities across russia
they say they're undeterred by today's
arrests and are vowing to protest
again next weekend so far the kremlin
has no comment coming up the man who
conducted more than
50 000 interviews
yes i am one thing i love canadians and
you have a great national anthem i agree
completely
much better than that
actor jay barachel is one of several
canadians larry king interviewed over a
career that spanned more than
half a century the broadcaster conducted
an estimated 50
000 interviews king died today at the
age of 87.
his cause of death has not been released
but he was hospitalized earlier this
month with covet 19.
he was known for his trademark
suspenders and his ability to get
elusive guess
here's a look back at the king of talk
and how he defined
conversation do you pinch yourself
saying come on you're one of the most
powerful women
in the world larry king was a
broadcasting legend
detroit hello for more than 60 years his
unique interviewing style brought
celebrities and newsmakers
into millions of homes how did you
emotionally hold up through all that
well i'm here i know but how what what
is it from presidents
i don't know as a matter of fact i've
never been in the watergate
uh never never been in the hotel never
never been in the hotel never been in
their restaurant
to a-list entertainers frank that's
still a kick
absolutely
king knew how to get people to open up
here and america loved it for 25 years
starting in 1985 he hosted cnn's larry
king live
at his peak king's show reached more
than one million people
each night i want to be surprised every
night the best shows for me
is when i go yeah wow in 1993 a debate
over the north american free trade
agreement
between vice president al gore and ross
perot was watched by 11 million people
at the time a record for cable
television born larry ziegler
king changed his name when he began his
radio career in the 1950s
he survived a heart attack in 1987 and
was married eight times
to seven different women after stepping
down from larry king live in 2010
king had second thoughts about
retirement and took a show to the
internet
debuting larry king now in 2012. i love
asking questions
i'm very much into people and you never
lose that
larry king a radio and television icon
he asked the questions americans wanted
to ask
dan schenemann nbc news
still ahead the revolutionary technology
decades in the making
that is so crucial to cover 19 vaccines
you're watching global national
on this day last year 11 million people
in wuhan china
entered the world's first coveted 19
lockdown those long
76 days were key to keeping the virus in
check
no cases have been reported there since
may and life has mostly returned to
normal
but in hong kong an outbreak of coven 19
has triggered the city's first ever
lockdown
the order covers the neighborhood of
jordan in kowloon peninsula
thousands of people must stay home for
48 hours and every resident in that zone
will be tested for the virus
the two vaccines approved for use in
canada have a
fascinating backstory they use a genetic
technology scientists have been working
on
for years it's called messenger rna or
mrna they knew it held promise and when
19 hit they ramped up research and
cracked the code
the results are the first mrna vaccines
approved for use
in humans and as donna friesen explains
the technology could revolutionize the
field of vaccines
zara kahia spends her days caring for
the vulnerable
she's a respiratory therapist in the
chronic ventilator unit
at capital care norwood in edmonton they
have
compromised respiratory systems and they
require
24-hour respiratory support when she
heard the pfizer biontec and moderna
vaccines were approved
she had questions i'm a numbers girl so
i tended to kind of read the studies and
that kind of
made me feel more confident in taking
this vaccine
they are mrna vaccines technology that
is revolutionary
but not entirely new scientists have
been working on it for decades
it's a very precise and elegant way
of of telling our immune system to
respond against
the virus this in simple terms is how
mrna vaccines work
the coronavirus's spike protein which
forms its crown
is what makes it so infectious mrna
vaccines work by
using that weapon against the virus
itself
like a computer code synthetic mrna
tells the cells of the body
how to make the spike protein scientists
had to find a way to inject it
without having the immune system
immediately attack it
they came up with a lipid nanoparticle a
kind of invisibility cloak
a fatty bubble that encapsulates the
mrna
and keeps it from being destroyed
allowing it to slip
into the cell once inside the mrna
is released and the cell starts building
the spike protein
mimicking a covid19 infection it is
completely harmless
but it triggers the immune system into
creating antibodies against the
coronavirus
it is a breakthrough that's advanced
work already underway on other vaccines
and treatment for other diseases
including cancer
kahia was the first person in alberta to
get the covet vaccine
the first question is are you okay and
then the second question
is should i get this vaccine and i
always answer with yes
donna friesen global news to learn more
about how the kobit 19 mrna vaccines
work
watch donna's entire story tonight on
the new reality
right here on global value village
riches up next what employees did when
they found a treasure at a second-hand
store
this next story begs the question what
would you do
if this happened to you employees at a
vancouver thrift store were sorting
through donation bags when they came
across
a hidden treasure 85 thousand dollars in
cash
and as nadia stewart reports it's what
happened next
that has everyone talking it is the
place where people go to get more bang
for their buck
thrifty deals without breaking the bank
but what staff found when sorting
through donations this week
was an unusual find to say the least
holy smokes
this is a lot of money jeffrey
stonehouse manages a value village in
vancouver
days ago he and another staffer were
sorting through a pile of donations
when they came across a bag that was
full of surprises
the bag was a little unusual it felt
like documents
and so she pulled out the first envelope
and tore the top off of it
and pointed it in my direction and what
we saw was a lot of
fifties and hundred dollar bills i don't
know how old this money is
i can tell you that the money had been
stowed away for quite
some time stone house says
even police were taken aback by the
amount over 85
thousand dollars the cash was in a bag a
dollar store bag no less
and a contained id that helped police
identify the elderly woman whose cash
this was
as it turns out there's an elderly woman
she's now living in a care home she's
been in the care home for about a year
and her family was going through some
old storage lockers that she had and
they found some bags of stuff
they decided to donate the bags to value
village
not obviously knowing what was in it and
never knowing that this money even
existed
the money is now on its way back to the
family with police praising
value village staff along the way they
did the right thing
they called the police stonehouse says
what he and his staff did
was what they always do when receiving
something they feel
was not intended for them usually it's
when we get a call from somebody they've
misdonated something
it's usually like my wedding dress or my
grad photos or something like that
but this certainly was outstanding this
was an unintended donation
they won't soon forget nadia stewart
global news vancouver and that is global
national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the hamlet of beaver creek saskatchewan
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night